[Music]
so i watched the first episode of the
orville
good morning
what did you think
um i thought it was very um
emotive i thought there was you know
some big deal going on there i thought
it was
perfect star trek
my name is ozymandias king of kings look
upon my works and despair
only there's nothing left beside it
except
empty desert i absolutely to be honest
adored it
but i love the order i love that show i
love stuck with ireland let's give this
everything we got and
may the force be with you
how was that perfect i thought it was
very well thought through
um but the second episode is bad
something happens in the second episode
oh okay so i really thought that you
know the first episode was
you know like it felt like last season
you know
and um
and i was really shocked that again the
twitter social outrage
the
the the accusations of locatude
of fox news fox news did a whole 20
minute segment on it
really i'm just like yeah
they talked about
some serious issues but it was fallout
from what happened in the last
series yeah so the whole battle the
whole thing with isaac there was it's
not like it was for no reason that they
were talking about suicide there was a
logical path towards what happened
you're kaylon your people would like to
see us all dead
and and it was trying to deal with
everyone's shock and yeah you know
trying to process what had happened um
you know don't ignore that i thought it
was quite realistic and quite um
quite powerful
yeah i mean you know it's it's
you know and i heard a lot of the story
from the this episode of the orville
i've heard from
um
u.s veterans from the iraq and
afghanistan wars it's like i've heard
this story before i've heard those
feelings before from other you know it's
like
this episode before but it's kind of in
real life but without the spaceships
[Music]
i think it did treat
it did a good one for you know the
issues the the really complex issues
surrounding suicide
and um
i mean that i i think that's what made
it a great episode um i really love to
develop the um budget
um i think the sets are really up when
our enemies don't
captain you are being deceived
i thought the only thing that was a
downside for me that whole thing with
the new fighter
i'm hoping that's going to be important
later because they spent a long time
they did you've seen that little thing
and flying it around and i know that was
also to do with that the woman could do
the five dimensions or whatever you know
right it was supposed to introduce her a
little bit but that went on for a while
and that was the only thing i would say
um so i want one oh yeah i want one but
it took a long time the second episode i
won't spoil it for you but it is classic
next generation sort of um sci-fi it is
absolutely
perfect if you like strange new worlds
you're gonna love this basically so
um who needs strange new worlds and
we've got the auroville
and everything's different on this side
of time
yeah well you know that was the other
thing i watched i got caught up on a
strange new worlds um
the thing that really drives me to just
absolute distraction
is pike's haircut man
yep i mean he i mean that's gone places
where no man has gone before i mean it
is it is a tower of
yeah
he's been working out as well but i
think that's the modern
um thing of star trek isn't it and
they've invented a hair gel in the
future that can actually handle that
um which is phenomenal um he spent a lot
of time working on that hair dude
considering he's supposed to be a
captain and you'd think he'd be busy he
also works out a lot i've seen the last
episode and he's got some pecs boy
wow yes you know and
during the the the first episode of this
he was riding around you know in the
snow on a horse
and he kind of had this grizzly adams
thing going you know look really good at
it but it did he didn't have the tower
of pisa
you know leaning off to the uh
over his right eye it was
the story was great i mean it was
awesome you know
and but it was like
pike man
i tell you what else i've been watching
them and i'm on the fourth episode of
the boys
which is a tv show i have to watch away
from my wife because um
says see you next tuesday word a lot and
she hates that word
um but um but yeah um i i just love that
show that that show appeals to my
childish side quite a lot
and then that blew up it's like like it
appeals on that side um and it's one of
those series that every so often you go
yeah i can't believe they're doing that
and i'm and i'm watching it it's like
but um i love that show it's um
it's
it's just ridiculous enough
but also if we'd really had super powers
it's also likely like
yeah human beings are that scummy that
we would actually do that if some of us
had superpowers so it's like um but i
love that series
[Music]